et poitou voilà ça l'important
or maintenant la science et comme
d'habitude pour cyril anosy hier ses
bibis ouais mais s'avère pas exact on
voit que l'extérieur ce qui marche i
puisqu'on est dans la sombre affaire
ouais non ce qui signifie en fait que
l'on peut provoquer le sentiment
amoureux
comment est ce qu'on fait alors il va
alors grasset c'est grâce à tout ça
voilà votre avis dégâts on va essayer de
rendre quelqu'un amoureux c'est ça oui
exactement
entraves en fait augmenter le flot
d'ocytocine c'est ça mais oui pourquoi
parce qu'en face il crée ensuite par
l'action de la dopamine est en réalité
ça va créer une sorte de différences
existent entre nos pères votre
l'ocytocine attention ici nous avons
évidemment des molécules carbonées qui
sont à moins 80 degrés quoi il faut
faire les manchettes à moins que de 1 à
4 touchés 2 touchés et on voit versé un
liquide ici il va réchauffer le tout
attention
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qu'on appelle un précepteur
d'ocytocine voilà je connais des coûts